German government crisis what damage has
been done in the interview Left Party
parliamentary leader Craig or Jeezy easy
the blunders made by Chancellor Merkel's
grand coalition the Adachi affair
relating to the possession of pictures
of naked children give the opposition a
clear opportunity gif is a feeling you
didn't capitalize is that deceptive yes
it is the problem is that politicians
already have a bad reputation this
situation will make our reputation even
worse and we'll all be affected whether
we're part of the government or the
opposition of course the situation is
quite serious involving betrayal
denunciation and mistrust first of all
the accused was tipped off an advantage
that was not justified but now he has to
deal with extremely negative media
coverage which is also not right the
rule of law and the presumption of
innocence still apply I don't understand
why Hans Pater Friedrich informed the
SPD leadership and not the Chancellor I
would have given the Chancellor the
information I had so she could make a
decision the Chancellor could have
waited until Sigma Gabrielle put
forwards of Astana dottie for the
position of interior minister and then
said no if he asked why she could have
said that he would find out in a few
days and that's it then there would have
been no betrayal no denunciation nothing
and it all went wrong in every way why
haven't you demanded the resignation of
the SPD parliamentary leader Thomas ah
per month his behavior has been
questionable throughout I've never
demanded anyone's resignation I demand
consequences to keep it from happening
again the SPD has to make its own
decisions for me the key issue is
stopping things like this from happening
in the future
it annoys me that the three party
leaders Angela Merkel host 0 Ferrand
Zigman Gabrielle are all talking but
they're not telling us what they've
agreed to
the German people have a right to
transparency and information I find it
incredible that when the SPD says it
won't sacrifice
Opperman as the CSU demanded the CSU
says in that case you have to let us
introduce road tolls so politics
degenerates completely it's like we're
in a bazaar or something
it really agitates me and therefore
we'll keep putting pressure on all I
have to say this whole situation has
damaged the image of politics they have
to realize that and we are holding that
against them that's muslin see I like a
boost time what does you just mentioned
the damage caused politicians have
confused the welfare of their party and
the state Kent politicians separate the
two always especially with legal
obligations
I mean Friedrich said the law was wrong
but it's not that simple when someone's
being tried in court they can't just say
it's the law that's at fault that way
you'll never get anywhere
but what really annoys me is this
half-hearted response and that's all to
do with the grand coalition they're too
powerful and they know they won't lose
that power regardless of what they do
here things coming down yes the mutual
trust between them has been dented you
can't forget that if the level of trust
in the government isn't right there will
be consequences on parliamentary work
and other things but with the European
elections for example they don't seem
interested they're raising their
expenses and just voting everything
through that's all to do with power when
you have almost absolute power abuse is
never far away let's go back to a don t
he was considered an honourable
politician and headed the Commission
investigating the terrorist NSU and he
did good work as everyone says but as a
Dottie's behaviour discredit the--and as
you Commission's work off PR by pieces
and I apply sisters also subscribe
that's not the Commission
because they published their findings
their findings have been established and
there was a unanimous resolution in
Parliament which is very rare but he
should have asked himself that question
at the time that's why even if he's
allowed to do what he's accused of doing
it's morally reprehensible I understand
the stance of Heiko Maas who's looking
at a new law on this issue but we have
to be careful pictures of naked children
have to be allowed in medicine in
science as well you can't ban them in
art and culture either but rather just
the commercial traffic you can't ask a
three or four year old if they consent
and it's a worldwide issue if you become
famous people around the world can
easily obtain pictures of you naked as a
child so I'm prepared to consider the
consequences as a build-off but with an
accident in this mind are consequences
see in most teen Vixen let's change
topics it looks like the tension could
be easing in Ukraine after approachment
between the opposition and President
Viktor Yanukovych's government
Yanukovych still seems to be clinging to
power it seems a bit like the end of
East Germany what's your advice for
Yanukovych I don't think he wants to
talk to me but I'd like to start out
differently both Russia and the EU made
mistakes Russia wanted closer ties with
Ukraine and the EU wanted the same thing
I think EU politicians didn't look
closely enough at Ukraine's full story
for example how Ukraine lies in the
cradle of Russia
that's how part of the population
predominantly speaks Russian and the
other part is more oriented towards
Western Europe Ukrainian society is
divided in this way if that have been
acknowledged straight away they could
have got on the right track from the
start and said Ukraine is a bridge
between the EU and Russia that's the
only way you can get a geostrategic
agreement secondly I think now that the
EU is taking action
Russia isn't doing enough I suggested
Gerhard schröder speak to Vladimir Putin
on behalf of the EU because the two have
a relationship based on trust murder
might convince him to change things I
hope that happens in their society
itself there were electoral observers
when the presidential elections were
held that's a big difference from East
Germany they never had that the
Ukrainian president clearly didn't
reckon with this resistance and then he
reacted disproportionately but of course
the opposition is not unified there are
democratic groups which we value and
then there are semi Democratic groups
and right-wing extremist groups who no
one wants anything to do with their only
common ground is that they're against
the president otherwise there's no
agreement on what should happen in
Ukraine that's where the deeper problem
lies if it falls into a civil war like
in Syria although no one wants that
that's what can happen in a divided
country the EU surely can't want that so
I say we need diplomacy diplomacy and
resolution we need to keep demanding an
end to the violence to talk to both the
president and the demonstrators after
all some of them are violent too and we
have to find a solution that's always
difficult the opposing sides need to
consider each other's interests I'll
explain it like a lawyer I know my
clients interests but if I don't know
the interests of my opponent I can't
find compromise if I understand their
real interests not just their demands I
can suggest concessions they can make
counter offers and then you come to an
agreement so I hope that happens and
that it works we want to avoid a civil
war in Ukraine in Europe at all costs
from angered or totally in the aftermath
of the Cold War are we experiencing a
battle over spheres of influence between
East and West yes of course the problem
is that the EU and the German government
initially underestimated Russia's
importance
that's also to do with how Boris Yeltsin
emerged the terrible totally amateurish
war in Chechnya and so on then Vladimir
Putin came and organized and structured
the country completely differently when
he marched into Georgia I think he
wanted to prove to the West that he
could do it
and within 48 hours if he wants to most
didn't pick up on that and are only now
realizing that they have to take Russia
seriously because of Syria the USA said
there could only be an agreement on
Syria that included Russia Putin wanted
that too
but the EU was reluctant to accept it we
have to do two things with Russia we
have to accept their power and
importance and their history and we have
to accept a man like pootie secondly we
can't stop calling for the rule of law
and more democracy we have to keep
bringing that up with actions too we
have to do that worldwide our
relationship with human rights disturbs
me we look away when it comes to Saudi
Arabia Saudi Arabia even gets weapons
from us I think that's wrong I tell
members of my party that they tend to
look closer in one place than in others
that's not right either
human rights have to apply always and
everywhere
that's gave me mention erase them isn't
it Molyneux but I get sad and she
thought there's a catch phrase at the
moment European elections you've already
had your party conference beforehand
there was discord over what your party
should do regarding the EU and Europe
lie it's the commander finebros but that
was all swept under the rug is that
because you can't make any gains if you
see anything against Europe see farm is
not mine up up Titus you're asking me
about my party that's always the hardest
part I prefer talking about other things
but the party conference was a success
we achieved two things that are
important in my view firstly we made it
clear that we're pro-european
and in favor of European integration and
the EU on the other hand we are very
critical of EU policy when it
- dismantling social welfare and
democracy and regarding military action
that was all expressed that means we can
say to people that we're not against
Europe but we do want a different Europe
a Europe where young people say yes to
Europe if I ask a young person in Greece
one of the 60% who are unemployed what
do you think he or she would say about
Europe
I can imagine I don't need to ask we
have to make sure that people see Europe
in terms of social welfare as a place of
democracy a place of more culture then
we have to take a few cultural steps
perhaps with the help of Deutsche Welle
what I want in Europe including Russia
is that all children are out of touch
that all children they're in the same
foreign language a generation of young
people who all speak one language Thank
You mr. Jeezy